phil when someone tells you that
filmmaking is a pipe dream
what's your reaction to that
it i mean
there's part of me that is yes it is and
the other part of me is like
no it's not look at me i'm i'm doing it
i'm i'm making things i'm making film
you know
it's uh you know i came into this
with no connection to the industry with
no family members in the industry
with uh i didn't go to university i
didn't go to film school
i didn't you know i it was it was as
from the bottom as you could possibly
imagine
just with me pouring over my jurassic
park annual from 1993 and seeing these
like
behind the scenes pictures of making
jurassic park thinking
that's what i want to do that's my
calling that's that's my thing
and yes it's a pipe dream but i'm gonna
find
i'm gonna chase it until it isn't you
know put every single thing
of my being into it because um
because it's only i think it's only a
pipe dream if you let it
you know it's it's um
it's uh i think for anyone
that is struggling to find a foothold or
getting those
doors closed at them or maybe doesn't
feel like they have that qualification
or you know or that piece of paper that
says you can do this thing i didn't even
know
how you filmed things or how things got
made or anything about it all i had was
passion and fascination with
film right you know it was jurassic park
for me and i you know
obviously pre youtube pre like
everything is at your fingertips
i got bought this annual in 1993
with black and white pictures
uh of behind the scenes jurassic park
and they blew my mind i was like
how is that thing that has just taken me
on this on this
journey to this world completely fake
you know like like who is this steven
guy and
how has he done that to me um so
um so everyone that back then said nah
it's like a you know oh yeah i was i was
like nine ten and i was like i'm gonna
be a director
i'm gonna i'm gonna be a director i want
to make films
people like okay what do you really want
to do
you know it's like you're you're fairly
smart like maybe
maybe you could do this and maybe you
could do that and i remember being
laughed at
by you know a kind of career guidance
person for
you know wanting to be a filmmaker and i
think on my like
automated test it said i needed to be a
dentist or something
um no offense to dentist but like that
wasn't me just to my core i've always
wanted
to do this and actually that's been a
blessing i suppose because
i've never really wanted anything else
so
so you know chasing the pipe dream is
like well i'm gonna throw my all into
this
and if i never get there you know
wherever there is
very different for different people um
you know i can't say i haven't tried you
know
uh i made those films i went to those
film festivals
i went on stage i acted i wrote i
did as much as i possibly could to build
those tools of a director so
maybe if and when i got that shot to
make something
i wasn't going to mess it up you know
and my shot came from commercials you
know which i never even thought in a
million years i was like he wants to
direct adverts
like you know and then you realize you
know they're a wonderful
proving ground and place to kind of uh
make things and also in a short uh
kind of a short-term um project basis
and it's supposed to feature something
to take years and stuff so
and obviously the money's very good and
that helps support other ideas and
shorts and things so
so yeah i never thought i'd ask the
nine-year-old
me like you're gonna make ads
commercials be like
no won't um so
um i would say
[Music]
it's only a pipe dream if you don't put
everything into it
because that's what it takes you know um
because you know
you are sort of toe to toe in a way
maybe a bad expression but you know
you're
you're against other people
that have you know amphors about passion
enthusiasm
and they're trying to make things as
well and and like
what's gonna make you stand out against
those other people
and certainly not laziness certainly not
sitting back
and waiting for that phone to ring
certainly not kind of being so
being proactive you know these are all
things that you need to do
to get your work out there get yourself
seen
um and to kind of nurture and grow
yourself
you know as a as a filmmaker um
so i'd say like anyone watching this
that doesn't have those contacts or
is facing all those shut doors it feels
like a little club
and you're always on the outside i'd say
firstly
you always feel on the outside like you
just do like you always think there's
this party going on somewhere that
you're not part of
maybe there is maybe this is me but um
you know you always feel like
you know you want to break down that
door get into that circle or connect
with those people
i don't think that ever goes away that's
just part of
it that's part of making film um
but also like if anyone tells you you
can't do it
it's like screw you i will do it and i
will show you i can do it and
uh and that's sort of what i did um
and then you know passion enthusiasm is
very infectious
and i remember i had some amazing
teachers
at the time in my high school um
who stayed late
with me so i could make films and they
oh you know we couldn't afford i can
afford a video camera you know we
couldn't
you know we couldn't afford a camera as
a family to make films which obviously
is a bit of a stumbling block
if you want to be a filmmaker and
obviously again pre-phones
having cameras and stuff um so you know
the the school bought a camera for the
department so i could make films
which i've forever indebted to so i
could and i've made as many films as i
possibly
could you know um a lot weren't very
good
but they they were my film school you
know they were they were my films
i grew and i showed people can make film
and people watch them
you know they got into festivals and
suddenly that pipe dream and that
thing that feels very kind of like a
child like hobby
you know it's like oh he's blessing he
wants to be a film director
so you're like oh wow he's making films
and people like them and
you know there's some progression
happening and because i was so in
i think partly so passionate and so kind
of
you know pig-headed i think about
that is what i'm gonna do and no one's
gonna stop me i think people
either support you or leave you alone
you know and luckily along the way i had
some wonderful people
and teachers that you know that
supported me so thank you donna
thank you tour people that
helped me grow you know um and
uh you know top of the oscars speech
so yeah it's um yeah
so is it not a pipe dream is that what
i'm trying to say
it's uh go get it that's a great story
so because the
the school had this camera oh sorry
yeah because the school had this camera
you were essentially able to to make
your first film
yeah um yeah i made my first film that
way and also
um we had a kind of friend of a friend
a neighbor who had a vhs camera
um and they uh i used to kind of clean
her house
so i could use her camera um
and um uh and also
um i learned editing because there was a
university
i think it was probably 4
15 um 14 maybe
and that was we had they had linear edit
suites like vhs tape
edit suites and before then i was
editing films on you know vhs players
like skye together and just like play
record play record
you know that's how i thought you would
edit things together
um so suddenly i had access to this
technology which now probably feels very
dinosaur is very dinosaur
but that really taught you how to edit
like working on a linear
system where like you make it edit and
if that
isn't right you have to start again from
the beginning like there's no drag and
drop there's no anything you have to
start again the whole thing
um and again that was by teachers and
people
you know they had friends or colleagues
like in the university
and they were like look can he come in
and a weekend and use that old dusty
stuff in the corner
you know to make stuff which i was very
very happy with
and thought was amazing um
[Music]
because you know with every film
i was making i was always so unhappy
with
some of the outcome you know i was
always kind of um
like oh on the next one i'm going to
improve that thing or maybe the sound
wasn't right i'm going to prove
that thing you know oh i didn't really
like the lighting and improve that thing
and that's actually what became my you
know as i say kind of my film school of
like
teaching myself um trying you know
what i was looking at you know big
hollywood films going why does my film
not look like that
i don't understand why can't i make my
film look like this
um so i was copying and emulating and
trying to make you know really low
budget
you probably call sweded version these
days of of
films and uh
you know to kind of learn learn the
ropes so um
so any kind of opportunity to learn
another tool
like editing or something i just grabbed
with both hands and and
and uh you know and it felt
that that was all knowledge i needed
uh the foundation i needed to kind of
call myself a director at some at some
point you know when i was making these
films
that's a great story i like that i like
that
and and what just just we'll move on
from here but
did the the the people that said you
can't do this it's a pipe dream did they
did they change
somewhat you know i don't know what
happened to that kind of careers
guidance person
um i think you know the the the
the teachers that supported me and
championed me and
were there you know and even like now
you know now being a parent i think wow
you could have gone home to your kids
like it's not easy being a teacher
in a high school you know kind of
comprehensive with all these kids
and then you stay late so i can make
some films like that's
that's actually pretty special at the
time i'm just like miss can you just
stay
so i can film that you know it's
actually the sacrifice that comes with
that
and they're still very much i'm still
very much in touch with them and still
very supportive and and
you know and stuff is great but yeah all
the um
i'm sure there's probably some
stiggering maybe from like fellow pupils
or other people thinking yeah good luck
like he like thinks it's gonna be
spielberg does he okay well
let's see um so maybe maybe hopefully
maybe they've seen some stuff
like oh okay he's making a living out
doing this thing
so um yeah don't don't listen to them
you know if you want to do it you've got
the passion for it
just go for it you know full
head first both feet whole body
everything in everything in
you